Climactic battles, guts, gore, and head-popping
antics all mark an over-the-top season of
"The Boys."
And what exactly is a "Herogasm?"
This is everything you need to know about
the ending of "The Boys" season 3.
"The Boys" Season 3 opens with our characters
in vastly different spaces than where Season
2 left them.
Yet the celebrity of the Seven remains strong
as the action-packed film, "Dawn of the Seven,"
opens in theaters.
Butcher teams up with the Seven's Queen Maeve,
who wants revenge on Homelander and longs
to ruin Vought's world.
"If we can find this…weapon, or whatever
it is, maybe we can use it to blow Homelanders'
f—ing brains out."
Frenchie and Kimiko enjoy a blossoming romance
and dream of escaping to Marseilles.
Mother's Milk re-enters his daughter Janine's
life and strives to become an excellent dad.
However, out of all of The Boys, Hughie's
life has changed the most.
The newly-confident protagonist and Starlight
have gone public with their romance, and Hughie
co-heads the Federal Bureau of Superhuman
Affairs alongside Congresswoman Victoria Newman.
He enjoys a tight workplace camaraderie with
Newman and feels like they're accomplishing
a lot in their mission to capture errant supes
with the help of government funding.
Alas, as always in "The Boys" universe, nothing
good can last.
Hughie soon discovers that Newman is actually
Nadia, a supe who grew up in an orphanage
for superhumans.
Video footage from Newman's childhood home
exposes her as the Head Popper from Season
2 and that she's been groomed since childhood
by Vought CEO Stan Edgar.
Hughie feels like a weak loser once again
and sets out on his darkest path yet.
Annie "Starlight" January remains the only
known supe with entirely pure motives.
Starlight yearns to change the Seven from
the inside until she realizes how fruitless
that mission is.
She sees the psychotic nature of Homelander
growing more threatening, and she's scared.
Alas, Hughie tells Starlight she needs to
continue her tenure in the Seven until they
can figure out a way to kill the leader of
the Seven.
When Starlight and Homelander attend a meeting
with Stan Edgar, he informs them that Starlight's
popularity points are up while Homelander's
have plummeted.
This has the unsurprising consequence that
the already-threatening stance Homelander
has toward Starlight grows fiercer and more
ominous.
Edgar tells Starlight that she will become
the first-ever female co-captain of the Seven.
She fears what Homelander will do to her and
must figure out a way to harness her newfound
corporate power to take the psychopath down
before it's too late.
Starlight recruits new Seven member and former
boy-band superstar, Supersonic, to help her
fight Homelander but has to learn to stand
tall in the face of her mounting fears.
Starlight's new role as co-captain of the
Seven presents many obstacles on her Season
3 journey.
In "The Boys" Season 3, Homelander finds the
public tides turning against him for the first
time.
As Stormfront's Nazi past is exposed, Homelander
is forced to explain his relationship with
her, exposing cracks in his veneer.
Homelander's narcissism soars in Season 3,
too, as he sees the weaknesses of other members
of the Seven as a reflection of himself.
He attempts to demean Starlight by demanding
that she sings a Marilyn Monroe-style "Happy
Birthday" to him on his televised birthday
special, and is incensed when she refuses.
Homelander hasn't dealt with rejection before,
and secretly it's his greatest fear.
The head supe falls into a dark space when
Stormfront kills herself.
He realizes he didn't buy into her plan of
building a master race because he is the master
race, in his mind.
Homelander believes he's better than anyone
else.
When Starlight leaks a damning video of Homelander
on social media, he decides to drop his "good
guy" charade.
He reveals the true disdain he holds for people,
and gains fans in the worst of humanity, who
feel represented by him.
"I'm not just like the rest of you.
I'm stronger, I'm smarter, I'm better."
Homelander no longer has a reason to hold
his darkest self back.
Antony Starr plays Homelander with subtle
malevolence that gives the character authentic
humanity, making him truly terrifying.
For characters like Butcher and Hughie, the
introduction of a 24-hour, temporary Compound
V serum proves to be a game-changer.
Queen Maeve secretly gives a few vials of
the superhuman serum to Butcher, in case he
needs to use it against Homelander.
"Temp V" causes a user to develop temporary
superpowers that wane within a day of the
drug's injection.
While the initial high of Temp V allows for
superhuman strength and other powers, the
detrimental side effects are equally as strong.
Butcher initially hesitates to use the drug
but eventually succumbs to its lure -– as
does Hughie.
Ultimately Butcher and Hughie both become
hooked.
The two experience horrific hangovers and
personality changes after using Temp V and
soon discover that prolonged use of the drug
will kill them.
Temp V opens up a plethora of storyline possibilities
and may play a pivotal role in future seasons.
By the season's end, the prolonged negative
effects of the superhuman drug become apparent
for Butcher.
Season 3 of "The Boys" ushers in the long-anticipated
arrival of Jensen Ackles as Soldier Boy.
Ackles plays Soldier Boy with sarcastic bad-boy
appeal, sans the good heart beating underneath.
"You should smile more.
I bet it's a beautiful smile."
Once the greatest supes in the world, Soldier
Boy was the leader of a mega-supe team called
Payback.
The group included future Seven member Black
Noir, Soldier Boy's lover Crimson Countess,
and Gunpowder, among others.
The world believes Soldier Boy died in 1984
while saving the world from nuclear annihilation.
The truth is far more dark and complicated.
Billy Butcher thinks the chemical that killed
Soldier Boy may be the only weapon that can
end Homelander.
His crew attempts to steal it from a clandestine
Russian lab, only to find a very much alive
Soldier Boy imprisoned in suspended animation.
After Butcher and Hughie take Temp V, they
free Soldier Boy and recruit him to help them
kill Homelander.
However, the team quickly learns that Soldier
Boy is as psychopathic as their nemesis.
Yet, the radioactive superhero can render
another supe powerless by blasting them with
his energy, so the Boys need him to take down
the Seven.
Alas, Mother's Milk has personal reasons to
want Soldier Boy dead, and once again the
group breaks apart.
Hughie and Butcher accompany Soldier Boy as
he locates his former Payback teammates.
The supe makes up for lost time by ingesting
hardcore drugs and reminiscing about his heyday.
Season 3 of "The Boys" may introduce us to
new characters, but the corruption of the
new supes mirrors that of those we already
know.
Through almost 40 years of torture at the
hands of the Russians, Soldier Boy discovers
that his former Payback team betrayed him.
In 1984 Nicaragua, the team is sent by Vought
to help new CIA agent Grace Mallory in the
historical Contra battle against the Sandinistas.
This is a fictionalized version of the battle
that sparked the real-world Iran-Contra Affair
scandal involving Oliver North.
Crimson Countess, the woman Soldier Boy once
loved, quickly hatches a plan to hand Soldier
Boy over to the Russians during the height
of battle.
The entire Payback team is in on the plan,
and Soldier Boy has nearly four decades to
plot his revenge.
Soldier Boy won't rest until he can torture
and murder his traitorous team.
The betrayal by the members of Payback, not
to mention Soldier Boy's egomaniacal personality,
once again proves even the best supes in history
were terrible people.
Butcher and Hughie set up Crimson Countess
by trapping her in the trailer where she now
lives to make her easy prey.
The Countess seems to have a part-time porn
site where she communicates with Seth Rogen
in a humorous cameo appearance.
The Countess is also a fierce advocate for
chimps and has released the sappy ballad "Chimps
Don't Cry" in their honor.
"You know that chimps are physically incapable
of crying?
But that doesn't mean they're not crying on
the inside."
The rest of the Payback team proves easy for
Soldier Boy to track down.
In Episode 6, an exclusive supe event called
"Herogasm" occurs, and it is exactly what
the name implies: an invite-only festival
of debauchery for supes.
"Wait, is this…?
Is this Herogasm…"
The event, hosted by the TNT Twins Tessa and
Tommy, former members of Payback and middle-aged
siblings with vague powers, gives us a visual
of the insane sexual appetites supes have.
Soldier Boy, Hughie, and Butcher head to Herogasm
to kill the twins, but Starlight shows up
with Mother's Milk to stop them.
Suffering from PTSD, Soldier Boy is unable
to focus his radioactive energy and ends up
killing or grievously injuring a myriad of
supes.
The build-up to the Season 3 finale really
starts here as character arcs and storylines
begin to converge.
Homelander shows up to battle Soldier Boy
and openly expresses fear for the first time.
Starlight publicly quits the Seven and shows
true bravery by attempting to stand up to
Soldier Boy.
She live streams a video where she calls out
most supes for only caring about themselves.
We're looking at a new Starlight, and she
is fierce.
The pieces continue to fall into place for
a final showdown between the good and bad
guys.
Any glimmer of hope we held for the redemption
of A-Train gets knocked to the curb in "The
Boys" Season 3.
Unable to run due to his addiction to Compound
V, which causes heart issues, the fastest
superhero decides to rebrand himself.
A-Train commandeers his race to promote a
self-serving and tone-deaf brand of energy
drink, Turbo.
In a mockery of the infamous 2017 Kendall
Jenner Pepsi commercial, A-Train stars in
an ad where protesters and police unite to
gulp down his new soda.
When A-Train decides to confront a C-list
Vought supe named Blue Hawk for his racist
patrolling of New Jersey, a tragedy ensues
that leaves his brother, Nathan, paralyzed
from the waist down.
A-Train manipulates the events of the tragedy
to serve himself, and when given a chance
to do the right thing, he fails.
Although he suffers constant abuse at the
hands of Homelander and the Deep, A-Train
continues to seek their approval and betrays
others to get back into Homelander's good
graces.
A-Train thinks he cares about others but focuses
on what will benefit him alone.
If Season 2 of "The Boys" brought us relationship
goals to aspire to through Frenchie and Kimiko,
then Season 3 solidifies the depth and authenticity
of their romance.
The love that Frenchie and Kimiko share grows
as they become more vulnerable with each other.
Although Kimiko still can't speak, the first
episode of Season 3 showcases her singing
voice as the former weapon of the Shining
Light Liberation Army belts out "Dream a Little
Dream."
Music provides a healing outlet for Kimiko.
She and Frenchie often snuggle up to watch
old musicals, and the two are showcased in
a phenomenal musical dance number.
Kimiko realizes she blamed Compound V for
making her a monster, but in reality, it's
her life-long conditioning by the Shining
Light Liberation Army and personal choices
that caused her to become a killing machine.
In the season finale, Kimiko tells a downtrodden
Frenchie that their past doesn't define them.
She thought she would always be broken, but
that Frenchie saw something in her.
And she sees it in him.
In Season 2 of "The Boys," Billy Butcher does
everything within his power to protect his
ex-wife, Becca, and her young son, Ryan Butcher,
from Homelander.
When he finally unlocks his powers at the
end of Season 2, Ryan shows his first signs
of superpowers with a tragic ending.
After that devastating event, Butcher stows
Ryan away with ex-CIA Deputy Director Grace
Mallory.
However, Homelander finally finds them and
tells his son that he loves him unconditionally.
The leader of the Seven even means it, as
much as Homelander can love someone other
than himself.
Ryan has longed to hear those words from Butcher,
but Homelander will suffice.
"Dad.
I wanna go."
Ryan's loyalty to his dad grows in the final
episode of "The Boys" Season 3.
He sees Butcher and his friends as the enemy.
After the showdown with Soldier Boy, Ryan
leaves with Homelander, and his psychotic
grin in the last scene of the season finale
does not bode well for his future.
The last action-packed scene of "The Boys"
Season 3 takes place in Vought Tower, the
home of the Seven.
Everything has led to this showdown, and it's
epic.
Soldier Boy gets the edge on Homelander, but
when Ryan intercedes, he turns his sights
on the boy.
Butcher will still do anything to protect
Ryan and can't let Soldier Boy hurt him.
For a singular moment, Butcher and Homelander
join forces against the mega-superhero.
Ultimately, though, it's Maeve who sacrifices
herself in the fight.
Homelander and Ryan fly away, but there is
little closure in the aftermath of the battle.
Both villainous supes survive the showdown,
leaving future storylines wide open.
"The Boys" still feels as timely and politically
resonant as ever.
The ending of Season 3 sets up the possibility
for another season, but we'll just have to
tune into Vought News Network to find out
what comes next.
"That b—h, has definitely got to go."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Boys"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.